president biden is hitting the road to
promote proposals that could remake
america in the years to come he'll be in
philadelphia today
and yesterday he traveled to duluth
georgia for a drive-in rally he's asking
for a multi-trillion dollar investment
by congress
in families and the country's
infrastructure wii xiang
has the story i want to thank you the
people of georgia
president biden made georgia the first
stop on a tour to sell his
infrastructure proposals a state that
gave democrats
control of the senate and power to
approve the covid relief package
we passed one of the most consequential
rescue bills in american history
now mr biden wants to spend four
trillion dollars on a pair of
infrastructure plans
one that focuses on creating new jobs
with projects to rebuild the nation
the other on supporting families with
measures like universal preschool
tuition-free community college and
expanded child care benefits
it's about time the very wealthy and
corporations start paying their fair
share
but republicans are slamming what they
call an extreme
spending spree what's being recommended
here
jeopardizes the future of our entire
country the massive amount of debt
to deal with an economy that's coming
back on its own
the president is also pushing for a
compromise on police reform
by the anniversary of george floyd's
death next
month and the conviction of george
floyd's murderer
is now our opportunity to make some real
progress to restore the
soul of this country floyd's family
lobbied lawmakers and
white house aides just as bipartisan
talks started up
our family's blood is on this
legislation
and so we want to make sure that it's
meaningful
legislation today president biden
continues his infrastructure blitz by
marking the
50th anniversary of amtrak in
philadelphia the president says he has
made more than
8 000 round trips by train between
washington
and his home in delaware during his
political career so many gail that his
nickname became
amtrak joe i remember that mijijang yes
he knows amtrak very well and they know
him
thank you weeja